[Music]
it was the wedding of the century 200
guests
including david arquette and courtney
cox cameron diaz and david spade
watch brad and jen say i do with the
help of a gospel choir and fireworks
show
off the malibu coastline
the newlyweds made their debut five
weeks later at the emmys
brad sporting a necklace with jen's name
on it i'm really excited to be here
thank you
and she's nominated yeah that's right
yeah i'm ecstatic
the pier was hollywood's most successful
couple brad had earned a reported 40
million the year before
and jen was about to earn a million per
episode for friends
we can do it all we will sleep when
we're 80. all right
all right babe i tell you i love my wife
brad pitt i love you
but not long after his ideas someone
else walked into brad's life
hi huge fan huge huge huge fan was this
hollywood's first bromance
jennifer aniston or me former sexiest
man
have you ever stolen anything ever i
steal hearts
don't you think though he should finally
join the married crowd
i've been married man i was there first
come on you should try the divorce crowd
you guys it's really fun
in 2005 brad and jen announced their
separation
then five months later the world saw
brad and angelina jolie
light the screen on fire in mr and mrs
smith
the world was divided you were either
team jen or team angelina
later that same year brad and angelina
made it official and by the end of the
decade
he was a dad of six i don't know how you
can be gorgeous every time you show up
for these and have the kids around the
house all morning
the dress goes on last week we've gone
out peed on without people